you know often we just start talking
occasionally before we start a podcast
and say let's stop and let's just think
what we should talk about oh you say
that every time but then we okay I say
it and then we don't you guys say oh
don't do that and we just start talking
and it works out today I said hey what
should we talk about and I was looking
to Sona and to Matt when suddenly uh
Aaron Blair who's sitting in the corner
uh like a Golem
um
uh what was your suggestion let's hear
it again
first try and recreate what your
suggestion was because you said it and
the three of us immediately blasted you
I what I said was it was quiet in the
studio everybody was thinking of an idea
no that's not you telling the idea okay
I'm the director here all right okay
okay I will set the scene I'm looking to
Matt and to Sona wondering anybody have
anything like maybe Sona you know your
father and his crazy mustache caught
fire you know if they are at the
Armenian cookout or or maybe Matt you
know you were strolling The Avenue in
Pasadena and you're uh The Fez you
bought at an option blew away something
fun like that you know uh or your
collection of uh you know uh Eleanor
Roosevelt stamps got lost and you didn't
know where they were okay but then
that's what I'm looking for when
suddenly Blaze distinctive voice types
up and says what everybody in La is
always bringing in fruit from their
fruit trees Conan do you have any fruit
trees that was your suggestion sorry
everyone brings in fruit from the from
the trees here at the office Conan
do you have said fruit
and we leaped we just leapt upon you
sure I even feel bad but I even I left
them yeah yeah I did too we were all
like what the what are you talking
about doubled down that's the part that
amazes me yeah rather than just
shrinking into the corner okay and
deciding not to speak for a year
uh and abstain from all sexual activity
you
you crept back up to the mic and went
but a lot of people do have fruit and I
was like you're doubling down oh and you
said like so-and-so brought in limes
yeah oh yeah Gina Gina brought in lines
yeah oh now you're on this side well I
was talking about bringing in lemons
from my tree incredible now this is a
chance for The Listener to see how my
job is the I'm the goalie and there's so
much terribleness that comes flying
around I'm with you although now I think
of it we have a lot of kumquats on our
tree all right yeah
no one gives a about any of this
stuff a lot of oranges too on one of my
trees grapefruits but today tack was
saying the guavas aren't coming in and
so I he was like does it skip a season
I don't know if fruit trees work like
that
foreign
of this introduction was for me to
explain how I'm trying to protect the
listener from this kind of banality this
uh you have a pomegranate tree I have a
pomegranate tree yes because uh I threw
a reception for you and Tac tactician
it's just Tech that's not his last name
I think it's tactical cesium but anyway
you I threw a wedding reception for you
guys and you and your parents very
nicely gifted me with a pomegranate tree
which I happen to know has great meaning
in the Armenian world yeah it means
prosperity and fertility and I think it
means well guess what since we planted
that tree my life has gone to
that tree is a blight
my teeth fell out
Beckett has turned his back on my son
turned his back on me will not speak
that's not the crows perch on my head
whenever I go outside it's not the tree
no it's not the tree I know and I do
keep a lot of
Crow food in my hair can I say another
thing I just got a text from David
hopping yeah uh your assistant who said
someone sort of remind Conan we have a
lemon tree here in the backyard here so
we have a fruit tree here all right get
David in here
who he's supposed to be the guru they
know it all he's in the corner he's
saying like yes we also have what did
you chime in here
yeah guess what Granite yeah up until
today because it's coming down that's
why we're all so fertile all right David
hopping yeah jump on please well I mean
it was after we bought this building
that we had babies that's true yeah
David hopping yeah you're supposed to be
my assistant you're listening to all
this out uh outside yeah in the office
building and you decide to send a
message to blay yeah then crazy
he's the guy dressed like didn't you see
that I was trying to stop all this fruit
talk why did you add to it I just
thought that you should know that you
contribute to the fruit oh you're just
as guilty
I took two of them last week wait you
took some of my fruit without asking me
I don't even know you had it I know but
now that I have it it's robbery okay
that we all deserve yeah
I don't there's a little tiny yard
behind our building I don't go back
there at all because apparently there's
sunlight there too uh like any good
vampire I must hide but uh but I'm it's
nice to know that we have fruit tree but
you have to pay me for that fruit no
yeah what is that what is the cost these
days of a lemon or a lime wait wait what
do you think the cost of a lemon or else
oh it's just gonna be one of those traps
that I'm an out of touch celebrity yes I
happen to know the running price for a
lime would be about 65
now in my defense I shop at Whole Foods
a Zing not far off
um yeah yeah buy fruit there you got to
bring someone to co-sign the loan
no one laughed at that not even to be
nice can we uh add laughter to that no
of course think so I think what we'll do
if anything is just put like a an older
woman sobbing on a street corner
markets is the universal language
well listen uh this was a um
what a terrible intro this this but you
know what to blaze defense he's like
talk about the fruit trees and then we
actually did talk about the fruit trees
right because so what you're saying is
that Blaze quip bore fruits that's what
you're saying
I mean have you seen the prices of a
cantaloupe when you go to
uh deals
I mean Whole Foods what the hell Jesus
Christ the other day I saw Bill Gates
walking out of there he said it's
highway robbery
I bought a strawberry I put it in my
will for my daughters again
this is old jokes about how expensive it
is at Whole Foods these are good jokes
though it starts to me being a comedian
who's also having a stroke okay it's
gone a little Dennis Miller in there cha
cha but also I'm just a guy that came up
in the clubs and if you've been to a
Whole Foods or lately let me tell you
something you better bring up Brink's
truck if you wanna get a grape you're
virgin on Stephen Hawking in that shirt
I love it I love this guy
this guy is funny and he's really
bringing life to the podcast
because he's got a real funny take about
Whole Foods being expensive
I'm dying I love this guy it's such a
Believer speaking guys yeah you're
having so much trouble talking I love it
yesterday and at Whole Foods on
onion and now my son can't go to college
now it's Popeye
I am who I am oh but I'm also Dennis
Miller but I'll show him having a stroke
coming off oh my God
oh
I was worried your head was gonna do
like a scanner's explosion trust me it
will oh man well
man time to get into it my guest today
is an academy okay
you never know when he's gonna come back
oh man he's got such a good take on
Whole Foods she does never heard that
joke but I also I love that this this
person won an Academy Award
this is an icon I know this is one of
the biggest icons we've ever had on the
podcast
I'm told she's leaving now on a
helicopter I hope this guy interviews
her hey James how's it going
what if Jane Fonda starts to tell a
great story about like well my father
and I'm like hey you ever been to Whole
Foods
Chief you do you better to bring
your accountant